over the years we've seen plenty of
right-wing politicians sully whatever
credibility they had left trying to get
into the good graces of donald trump and
oftentimes it ends up just completely
backfiring or they get into trouble over
it and the next person to be following
this trend appears to be trump's fourth
and final white house chief of staff
mark meadows and that is because meadows
is no longer cooperating with the
january 6th congressional committee
meaning that if his abstinence continues
charges could indeed be coming his way
now as recently as a few weeks ago
meadows was cooperating with the january
6th committee he was providing them with
documents and really naming names like
the whole reason we know about the story
having to do with sean hannity and brian
kilmeade and laura ingram urging
meadows to tell trump to end the
insurrection was because meadows was
willing to hand over the documents he
was willing to hand over those text
messages to the committee obviously we
also found out that don jr was trying to
urge meadows to put an end to it and we
also found out that congressman jim
jordan was giving an outline to meadows
as to how mike pence could throw out the
electoral college votes in states that
they were contesting so this is all
based on the fact that meadows was
complying with the committee's requests
and handing over the documents but
everything changed around the time
meadows released his book the chiefs
chief and trump publicly lambasted
meadows for the claim specifically that
trump exposed people to covid after he
tested positive for the virus
and one of those people that he exposed
was actually joe biden during their
first debate trump called the allegation
fake news and meadows backtrack saying
oh yeah that part of my book that was
fake news apparently regretting that he
upset his former boss meadows thought
that the book was going to flatter trump
and instead it mainly just got under his
skin because of the media coverage
having to do with that positive test it
did the exact opposite of what he was
trying to do it was right after this
incident that meadows halted his
communications with the january 6th
committee the january 6th commission
wanted to get meadows to show up in
person for testimony uh meadow's lawyer
george terwilliger argued he had done
enough he had provided the documents and
the committee should be satisfied with
that in fact tara willager released a
statement that reads quote the select
committee's true intentions in dealing
with mr meadows have been revealed when
it accuses him of contempt citing the
very documents his cooperation has
produced so what mark meadow's attorney
is saying here is that basically you
should be grateful to my client because
so much of this information that you
have now is because he was willing to
cooperate with the investigation you
shouldn't be turning around now and
trying to rope him into testifying if he
doesn't want to he shouldn't be
threatening him with criminal charges
because you know he's given you so much
already and it is true that mark meadows
was fully cooperating and handed over uh
9 000 pages of documents even though
some of that information was indeed
damaging to meadows and to the former
president he still did do that but you
don't really get partial credit when
you're talking about a select committee
that has the rule of law behind them and
if you're not going to do everything
that they ask of you then you're going
to open yourself up to criminal exposure
and that's exactly what's happened here
recently the house voted to refer mark
meadows for criminal contempt of
congress charges and it's going to be up
to biden's justice department and
attorney general merrick garland to
decide whether or not he's actually
going to be charged and if he is and
he's found guilty there's actually the
possibility on the table of mark meadows
serving prison time over this now is
that actually going to happen i don't
know he may not even get charged in the
first place because it's going to be
seen as an overtly political act if this
happens like yes bannon was charged in
this investigation but he also wasn't
willing to comply at all
and bannon was in trump's administration
but only as an advisor whereas mark
meadows like he was the chief of staff
after all it's a much more important gig
and so maybe they would just figure that
biden and biden's justice department
wouldn't have the political capital to
charge mark meadows for his abstinence
in this case but we'll have to wait and
see and then obviously if he does get
charged that doesn't mean necessarily
he'll get convicted and if he does get
convicted that doesn't mean necessarily
that he'll go to prison over it he may
just face a fine or something like that
so we'll have to wait and see what
happens but you never know like
this could definitely happen and there's
definitely some legal exposure here and
meadows i'm sure is probably not
sleeping very well at night uh these
days and that's all because of donald
trump and he was trying to get on
trump's good side and now at the end of
the day he's not only on trump's bad
side uh he's also
running the risk of criminal charges so
that's mark meadows for you and now
there's this very very long list of
people who went down for donald trump's
sake you already thought it was long
enough well it's getting even longer we
have people on there like roger stone
steve bannon paul manafort michael flynn
rick gates george papadopoulos michael
cohen we know that rudy giuliani of
course is in trouble he's under
investigation and he's also facing that
civil suit with dominion voting systems
there's people like
mike lindell and sydney powell who are
also running against that case with
dominion voting systems so is mark
meadows the next to follow the next to
get in trouble trying to get into the
good graces of donald trump we'll just
have to wait and see but you'd think
that all these people would learn their
lesson by now
on the bonus show today we have some
great stories we're going to talk about
how kim potter the former police officer
she has been found guilty in
manslaughter charges having to do with
the the killing of dante wright kim
potter of course was the officer who
confused her service weapon with her
taser and she thought that she was
tasing dante wright but she actually
shot and killed him
she has been found guilty now so we'll
see what happens with sentencing we'll
see the reactions to all of that we're
going to talk about donald trump
declaring victory on the war on
christmas he talked to mike huckabee
about how before trump was president no
one would say merry christmas and you
weren't allowed to but ever since trump
served in office now all of a sudden you
can say merry christmas and i also want
to talk about a recent covet scare that
i had i think many of you will find that
story interesting if you want to watch
the bonus show today go to
joinpackman.com and sign up for a
membership or you can go to patreon.com
david pakman show and sign up for a five
dollar membership there that's going to
do it for today that's going to do it
for the week merry christmas to everyone
david will be back next week and we'll
see you then